jonathan k
is a senior editor at the online
magazine
quillette which is always an interesting
uh read over the years he's written big
meaty essays on all the big subjects
war pestilence social justice gender
dysphoria
inuit whale hunting and none of it went
anywhere
until the other day when he did a
throwaway
tweet revealing that for the last three
months
he'd accidentally been washing his hair
with his dog's shampoo
and next thing you know big time
hollywood star seth rogan
and small time lefty hack keith
olbermann and the rest of the blue
checker were pounding on him jonathan
k uh joins us uh tonight
uh jonathan as i think you put it in one
of your tweets
uh this this escalated rather quickly
yeah it was really strange it was
supposed to be
this self-deprecating joke and uh
you know i i tweeted it and then i i
don't know i think i walked my dog
and then i checked my phone it was like
seth rogen
was calling me names it was a very
surreal way to spend my sunday morning
and then that thing that happens that
you really don't want when you're in a
twitter spat
with seth rogen is that your mum decided
to chip
up on chip in on your behalf and suggest
that he work
this into a subplot for his next movie
and you didn't appreciate that well
it's not a good look uh when family
members jump in
uh but i was very disappointed in seth
and by the way i just you know at first
you know my response to him was like
look maybe this guy is going through a
bad thing he got into spats with
with with certainly people who more
famous than me like god said and
rudolph giuliani and i was giving him
the benefit of the doubt i said hey look
i love your movies
you know you know maybe you're having a
bad weekend or something like that
and but like i kind of gave them the
opportunity to say hey you know what
i'm i have nine million followers and
here i am chasing down some
random toronto journalists you're right
i'm i'm being stupid
i'm the one being stupid but he he never
he never got to that point
it was really um it was disappointing i
like seth rogan's movies i was
disappointed
he seems like a nice guy when you're
looking on screen this is no no this is
unbecoming of you because
he went he he said i thought you were
the most stupid guy on the planet for
the dog
shampoo thing and then he googles you
and he finds
you were in you you didn't think the
january sixth thing was a white
supremacist
insurrection and then he starts beating
up anew for that so it's not just that
you're
a guy who wears dog shampoo but then he
discovers that you're a dog shampoo
racist hater white supremacist too don't
don't apologize and say nice things
about seth rogen's lousy movies jonathan
well look by the way i just i i tried to
make it clear to him and said look
you're misunderstanding the title of the
article you're referring to i
myself mark you of all people know this
i myself can be a very sanctimonious
leftist
and so i expected that there would be
some solidarity
expressed between uh urban
jewish sanctimonious leftists but
apparently there's none
and i uh i'm actually more disappointed
than angry
but i i disagree with you on those
movies i thought
[Music]
uh
you're like an abused victim uh trying
to say nice things about your abuser
jonathan
man up about as that uh super bowl guy
would say
um listen i saw the green hornet
no we're not doing anything let me let
me ask let me ask you this
we because we did a couple of minutes
ago this story about
the conservative snowplow driver that
the
liberal lady didn't want plowing your
driveway
are we in a world where you can't
actually you can't actually
make a self-deprecating goofball
joke and then uh accept uh without it
going to racist hater in 40 seconds
you know that honestly that was the most
disappointing part of this
is that um like i mean all my other
sort of political propaganda that i
admit sure whatever you know call me
this call me that
but don't hate me because of my
beautiful hair and
it uh it got to the point it got to the
point that my
my my kids came home from from school
from virtual school and they said
dad you're trending i was like oh no
that's true that's never because that's
never a good thing thank you
thank you your hair looks fabulous your
hair looks fabulous i'm entering you in
the
westminster kennel club show next uh
next month a personal grooming tip by
the way
i'm wearing my hamsters exfoliant that's
it
for us